[Música]
hola mi nombre es salva soler quieren
hablar de poesía
probablemente la mayoría de vosotros
cuando hecho la palabra poesía habéis
pensado vaya a piñazo
pero os pido que me deis una oportunidad
de 15 minutos para intentar abrir una
perspectiva un poquito diferente
sería la misma pregunta a la cuánta
gente no le gusta la poesía que no lo
voy a hacer con compromiso nos preocupa
probablemente más de un 70% levantaría
la mano y eso es pregunta a las razones
yo pero serían las mismas no
es aburrida no lo entiendo el lenguaje
es muy lejano no es sólo contar si le
vas a rimar no me transmite nada
pero cuando decimos que algo es poético
es que es bello
cuando decimos que un paisaje es pura
poesía es que es hermoso
como puede ser entonces que algo para
todo el mundo está relacionado a algo
bello sea aburrido y esa misma gente no
le transmita nada
pues señoras y señores porque nos han
educado mal así de claro
hay un rechazo y un prejuicio y lo
entiendo porque es el mismo rechazo y el
mismo prejuicio que yo sentía cuando la
estudiaba en el colegio yo la aborrecía
y ahora me dedico a la poesía
qué es lo que cambió entonces para que
yo pasara de aborrecer la a dedicarme a
ella pues pues que yo jamás aborrecía el
que aborrece el como él como la forma en
la que hacemos las cosas es lo que hace
que el que en este caso la poesía llegue
y conecte con los demás
yo odiaba el brócoli hasta que llegó
alguien y me lo cocinado de forma
diferente y sabrosa
por ejemplo me encantaba la historia
porque tenía un profe en clase que
llegaba el tío y nos decía van a ver hoy
vamos a estudiar la batalla de waterloo
levantados todo el mundo de pie tú vas a
hacer de napoleón todas las de caballo
lo siento nos faltan personajes te vale
y nosotros la recrea vamos entonces la
aprendíamos y la recordábamos porque le
habíamos vivido como una aventura en vez
de apoyarlas sentados como si fuéramos
robots
amamos algo cuando establecemos un
vínculo emocional con ese algo
y es muy difícil establecer ningún tipo
de vínculo con la poesía porque nos la
enseñan de forma aburrida con los mismos
textos antiguos de siempre y como algo
mental y no emocional
luego voy a hablar a la educación porque
para mí es la base de todo pero chicos
tengo que reconocer que no ayuda mucho
que la poesía no ha evolucionado al
mismo ritmo que otras artes vamos a
comprobarlo vamos a ver por ejemplo
visualicemos
música visualicemos concierto de cámara
barroco concierto de queens copa estamos
vibrando a tope muy bien evolución
genial vale teatro coro griego gritando
o feos gran zeus
el rey león la cigüeña evolución
perfecta muy bien cine o televisión
series no cine mudo
juego de tronos
spoiler perdón poesía
100 cañones por banda viento en popa a
toda vela
me gusta cuando cayó porque estoy como
ausente
ausente está la evolución vale estamos
con las mismas imágenes desde hace más
de un siglo y no tengo nada en contra de
ellas igual que no tengo nada en contra
de la música clásica me encanta pero
la poesía necesita hacerse adulta y
salir de los límites cerrados académicos
en los que la encerraron de libertad y
diversidad para ser lo que cada uno
quiere que sea igual que el cine la
música o el teatro evolucionar y
conectar con la gente de la calle
os voy a poner un pequeño ejemplo voy a
recitar un poema mío esto es un poema de
amor
esto se llama
tal vez quieres que sea constante cual
reloj de arena que sea el sentido de una
vida entera que sea tu brújula si estás
perdida que te lleve en brazos cuando
estés vencida la gota malaya que está en
que tus dudas la ola que vuelve y mete
tus culpas
que salpique mares que ilumine estrellas
que derrita soles que de sant de huellas
que sea constante que sea constante que
sea constante que sea constante
si tú quieres puedo puedo ser constante
o tal vez quieres que sea tan rápido que
se presente un silencio en las pausas o
que sea
en que separó el mundo
durante el segundo que duró nuestro
primer beso
tal vez quieres eso que dilate el tiempo
o que sea
o tal vez quieres que sea grande grande
grande grande inmenso arrollador que
tenga la personalidad del mejor villano
da fuerza a un espartano que eclipse
estrellas con las manos que sea tu big
bang' y antes de conocer cualquier
teoría que mi honda expansiva provocó tu
implosión que te derrita que tenga tanta
rabia acumulada que mi grito sea tu
bandera en mil batallas que ocupe tanta
densidad en tu existencia que te sientas
un agujero negro en mi presencia que ni
avances ni retrocedas que ocupe tanto
espacio en tu existencia que te sientas
un meteorito a la deriva mis ausencias
límite estrellas ni te detengas si tú
quieres puedo ser tan grande
o tal vez quieres
del sudor la gota del polvo la mota que
quepa un poco de tu piel el entretejido
de tu vestido que sea vulnerable una
partícula en tu aire que me lleves
centro
este ruido
que me lleves encima sin haber tenido
ser solo tú con otro espada ser solo tu
patita en otros garras tú quieres puedo
puedo ser pequeño o ansioso nervioso que
más llega a transmisión voz os queremos
sin sentido haciendo los corzos posesión
bailarín maravilloso sensual sexual
ritmo y marcado perfecta ejecución con
control o que vaya por la oea a lo
cubano botella de ron tabaco habano o al
argentino martín alfajor estoy propio de
la existencia condicional estado químico
el propio peso del que vamos
transformando se remedia una atracción
de dos cuerpos en un campo
o simplemente hacerte reír si tú quieres
puedo pues ser constante tapar el
silencio o estar callado dilatar el
tiempo puedo ser inmenso puede ser
pequeño pues el gracioso poseer nervios
o bailar te alrededor o ser tu eje ser
tu confesor un confidente [ __ ] te tan
rápido que te sientas amada
amarte tan lento
que te sientas follada puede ser un
nómada que forja hogares o puede ser una
entraña de dos mitades es tu quieres
puedo tú quieres vuelo esto querés sueño
si tú quieres vuelvo sólo dime
[Aplausos]
esto me referí a una poesía que tenga
energía emoción ritmo poder sutileza
humor que pueda conectar con todo el
mundo en mis espectáculos hay gente de
13 a 80 años he recitado en el
parlamento europeo en algunos de los
festivales más importantes del mundo en
13 países diferentes y os tengo buenas
noticias
ya existen nuevos formatos de presentar
la poesía oral y la literatura hablada
el spoken word los van a flipar
yo fui campeón de españa y medalla de
bronce la copa del mundo de poetry slam
en 2015 el slam es el más popular de
todos esos formatos existe por todo el
mundo y en él el público vota y decide
un ganador
teniendo en cuenta que el texto que ha
de ser propio es tan importante como la
forma de presentarlo el qué y el cómo
se ha hecho tan popular en países como
francia brasil alemania o eeuu y en eeuu
ha pasado de ser un movimiento surgido
de la calle de la gente a estudiarse en
la universidad
os pongo otro ejemplo chulo junto a otro
es lamer maravilloso dan y orbitz
tenemos un espectáculo teatral llamado
combate poético a cinco asaltos en el
que vamos vestidos de boxeadores
en resultado está dentro de una iglesia
al principio pensamos en los puristas de
la poesía nos van a perseguir para
pegarnos a nosotros pero con palos
pero la gente sale del teatro y nos dice
mira en mi vida hubiera ido a ver un
recital de poesía pero es algo vibrando
me he divertido y me emocionado esta
poesía sí me gusta
pues igual podemos cambiar la forma de
presentar la poesía podemos cambiar la
forma de enseñarla
soy profesor en la escuela superior de
arte dramático eolia y soy profesor de
poetry slam en institutos y os diría que
para mí uno de los mayores problemas que
tenemos en la educación es que
absolutamente nadie nos da jamás dos de
las cosas más importantes y necesarias
uno nadie nos enseña cómo gestionar
nuestras emociones cómo entender lo que
sentimos y dos
nadie nos da herramientas para
comunicarnos bien en público con los
demás
vale
pues qué es la poesía oral si no eso
vamos a enseñarla así vamos por pasos
uno en vez de empezar estudiando lo que
escribe un tío en el siglo 17 vamos a
empezar escribiendo lo que sentimos
nosotros ya sea sobre un amor la
relación con nuestros padres si no hacen
bullying en el cole o si necesito jugar
la consola para evadirme de la realidad
escribamos dos cuando tenemos ese texto
vale empezamos a jugar con el lenguaje
de forma divertida propia pong hables
metáforas rimas lo que nos dé la gana
3 empezamos a estudiar poesía más
cercana urbana moderna con la que nos
identifiquemos 4
leamos nuestro texto en voz alta con el
resto de la clase o del colegio sintamos
que nuestra opinión es escuchada
y 5 para que llegue esa opinión
básicamente que nos dé herramientas para
poder comunicar bien nuestro mensaje en
público por ejemplo
cómo superar el miedo y la vergüenza
cómo conectar visualmente con los demás
no es lo mismo hablarle a alguien así
que hablarle a alguien así
como masticar bien las consonantes para
que se nos entienda toda comunicación
verbal está en las consonantes
no es lo mismo marcar las consonantes
pero marca la persona de anaga
consonantes consonantes ok
como proyectar bien nuestra voz para que
se nos escuche teniendo energía para
llegar al punto más lejano del lugar en
el que estamos jale o sea no es lo mismo
hablar así hablar así
hemos de intentar llegar hasta ahí
nuestro mensaje puede ser maravilloso
que si no se entiende y no se escucha no
llega
cómo utilizar el lenguaje no verbal es
el 80% de toda comunicación sólo el 20%
es la palabra el otro es el cuerpo como
nos estamos vivos no pues estamos vivos
transmitamos con vida nos no hay esos
como palos
cómo ser naturales y expresar emociones
verdaderas
no sonar fingidos porque estamos
provocando la empatía de quien nos
escucha
y cuando hemos finalizado este proceso y
amemos la poesía por la sintamos como
algo cercano entonces sí que vengan y
nos digan mira chicos pues había unos
tíos en el siglo 17 llamados quevedo y
góngora que escribían de las mismas
cosas que vosotras pero con un lenguaje
de la época hoy me podrá gustar más o me
podrá gustar menos pero no tendré un
prejuicio ante toda la poesía ni tampoco
un rechazo
la poesía puede generar belleza puede
empoderar y puede reclamar justicia
puede despertarnos el ingenio y puede
ser divertida
sé que para muchos mezclar poesía y
humor es como mezclar horchata y chorizo
os voy a dar otro ejemplo antes de irme
este poema estoy federal en redes lo
vieron casi dos millones de personas y
es un poema escrito única y
exclusivamente con títulos de películas
no hay nada añadido que no sea un título
y con esto os voy a explicar la historia
un señor que se llama harry y esto se
llama
2001 noviembre en busca de la felicidad
cuando harry encontró a sally mamá mía
amor a primera vista la primera cita un
domingo cualquiera un día las carreras
una tarde en el circo una noche en la
ópera qué noche la de aquel día mejor
imposible
28 días después 'leyendas de pasión'
28 semanas después el apartamento los
mejores años de nuestra vida y cuando
menos te lo esperas
cásate conmigo
la ley del silencio
angustia de que si la duda
en nueve semanas y media la gran boda
los invitados los padres de ella los
padres del novio el hijo de la novia
historias del pasado hermanos de sangre
primos los amigos del novio 12 monos
hombres de negro casi 300 el hombre de
traje gris
el niño tija más rayas los chikos del
maíz' 13 fantasmas 7 vírgenes solas
nadie hablará de nosotras cuando hayamos
muerto hasta que llegó su hora
la novia mujeres al borde un ataque de
nervios el pianista lalalala and
cámara oculta play break
shrek
el sacerdote y llegó el momento el
padrino
el padrino 2
la dama de honor el señor de los
anillos'
hasta que la muerte os separe prometemos
el beso la novia cada vez
flash cadena perpetua clic novia a la
fuga quédate a mi lado volver olvídate
de mí y tu mamá también'
buenas noches y buena suerte
además la siguiente el hundimiento el
increíble hombre menguante harry el
sucio entre copas chocolate speed 21
gramos
psicosis bichos la semilla del [ __ ]'
la rabia que he hecho yo para merecer
esto sed de venganza
haz lo que debas 'toro salvaje' empieza
el espectáculo camino pasado de vueltas
colega dónde está mi coche
sin pistas gran torino gris
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el azul el otro
merziq tron el [ __ ] sobre ruedas de
ring llamada perdida
mensaje oculto
ella
here
una verdad incómoda
recuerdos mortales el rascacielos de la
muerte subida al cielo planta séptima al
filo del abismo en vértigo
ser o no ser decisión crítica
en el nombre del padre saltó al vacío
ahora el vuelo y grito aterriza como
puedas el golpe el cuerpo la sangre azul
oscuro casi negro'
cómo
el día después habitación 33 cesc alma
total y entonces llegó ella culpable sin
perdón
si fuera fácil te doy mis ojos'
mientras duermes lo imposible aliento
señales despertares despierta lo siento
te quiero ponte mi lugar
la huida mientras duermes el sexto
sentido de javi
no había la fuga quédate a mi lado
volver
olvídate de mí y tu mamá también'
buenas noches
adiós pequeña adiós la muerte tenía un
precio el perdón
bieber es fácil con los ojos cerrados no
tengas miedo
el resplandor
amanece que no es poco hoy puede ser un
gran día el primer día del resto de tu
vida recuerda el cielo puede esperar la
vida es bella posdata te quiero bien
[Aplausos]
pues a esto me refiero a cambiar el como
la poesía no es aburrida nos han hecho
aburrir la poesía no es algo lejana nos
han hecho sentir como algo lejano ojalá
la próxima vez que os pregunten te gusta
la poesía respondáis sí o comimos
respondáis oye mira pues depende del que
y sobre todo depende del como muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]